大家好,下面我给大家演示一下如何进行分销铺祸,首先点击铺祸模板,点击添加模板,模板的名称可以根据自己的需求进行设置。
下面的内容也是根据需求进行选择,这里我们看一下商品的价格设置,商品的价格可以设置统一的倍率模板,也可以按照区间进行设置,比如说0-10元。
一个倍率,设置好后点击添加,然后10-20元一个倍率,设置好以后点击添加,20元以上一个倍率,点击添加,然后这下面点击确定,祸祸模板就设置好了,接下来就可以选产品铺祸了。
选品铺祸一共分为三种方式,一种是1688选品,一种是图搜同款,还有一种是连接铺祸,我们先看一下1688选品。
上面可以筛选条件,然后输入您想铺祸的产品关键词,比如说我要铺祸眼镜,然后搜索。
这里会出现很多产品,您可以整页勾选,点击全选,就是整页勾选,50个产品,也可以根据自己的需求,挨个选择。
比如说选中产品,然后点击批量铺祸,然后选择您刚才设置的模板,点击确定,铺祸任务就设置好了,然后点开铺祸记录,点击查看,
就可以看到您刚才提交的铺祸任务,然后我们再看一下图搜同款,图搜同款这里需要复制图片的地址,您可以提前往图片的地址,点击一下,然后复制到框里,点击搜索。
这里就可以出现图片的同款,您可以选择想要铺祸的产品,进行铺祸。
也是选择您刚才设置的模宝,点击侧布。
铺祸任务就设置好了。
同样也是在铺祸进入这里,可以查看您刚才提交的铺祸任务。
最后是连接铺祸。
这里直接复制1688产品的连接,进行铺祸就可以了。
点击批量铺祸,然后选择您刚才设置的模板。
点击确定。
任务就设置好了。
同样也是在铺祸进入这里,可以查看您刚才提交的铺祸任务。
好的,分销铺祸就演示完了。
赶快去试试吧。